pas
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat un fonds public
d'indemnisation pour les victimes du
médiator va être mise en place avant la
fin de l'été c'est ce qu'annoncé la
semaine dernière xavier bertrand
ministre de la santé un texte devrait
donc être présenté en conseil des
ministres d'ici la fin du mois au début
mai pour un vote définitif par le
parlement avant la fin de l'été ce n'est
toutefois pas le contribuable qui
financera ce fonds mais bien les
laboratoires servier a indiqué xavier
bertrand les laboratoires servier qui
d'ailleurs devrait payer plus cher car
ils seront contraints par une loi
c'est donc dans ce contexte que la
mission d'information du sénat sur le
scandale du médiator a organisé une
table ronde avec des associations de
patients table ronde que je vous propose
de suivre tout de suite bonne matinée à
tous mesdames messieurs bienvenue donc
nous allons commencer cette audition en
l'absence voulons marquer de madame le
rapporteur qui est pris par le débat sur
la bioéthique
peut-être qu'elle va pouvoir nous
rejoindre avant la fin de cette audition
mais je vous le promets pas j'essaierai
de la remplacer même si c'est une tâche
qui est difficile pour moi enfin
j'essaierai de faire pour le mieux donc
mes chers collègues nous allons donc
poursuivre nos auditions ce matin
excusez moi avec les représentants donc
d'un certain nombre d'associations et
qui joue un rôle très important dans le
domaine de du médicament et de la santé
alors nous avons donc organisé cette
table ronde avec les représentants des
associations suivantes
monsieur dominique michel courtois ici
présents qui est président de
l'association des victimes de
l'isoméride et du médiator jeu karim
felissi conseiller national et madame
marie hervé le de la fnath l'association
des accidentés de la vie
madame sophie le pallec présidente de
l'association des malades des syndromes
de laguiole et de stevenson sommes
monsieur gérard en remo de l'association
française des diabétiques et nous
attendons monsieur christian saout
président du collectif interassociatif
de la santé pardon monsieur south
excuses il sera pas là après il sera pas
présent il est à une commission sur la
dépendance mais il nous a chargés bien
de répondre à sa place toute façon vous
êtes membre du sis nous sommes membres
du site donc un an vous allez vous allez
prendre les deux casquettes
vous pourrez intervenir dans votre
intervention vous pourrez donc que nous
parler aussi du cices parfait bien alors
je vous rappelle un pour être clair que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et fait l'objet d'un enregistrement
audiovisuel en vue de sa diffusion sur
le site internet du sénat et
éventuellement sur la chaîne public
sénat
donc je voilà comment nous allons
procéder je vais
vous donnez la parole à tour de rôle et
ensuite nous vous poserons un certain
nombre de questions aussi qui nous
apparaîtrons à la suite de cette
audition
donc je vais passer la parole par ordre
de 2 en procédant de la gauche vers
l'art de la droite vers la gauche de la
droite vers la gauche effectivement
madame sophie le pallec donc vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président de nous
donner l'occasion de s'exprimer notre
point de vue de faire connaître
l'association analystes nous
représentants les victimes des syndromes
de laguiole et de steven johnson pour
présenter rapidement ces maladies ce
sont des réactions très graves qui se
traduisent par un décollement brutale de
la peau et des muqueuses décollement
parfois très très étendue
la victime doit impérativement être
prises en charge dans une unité
spécialisée
la douleur est évidemment extrêmes il ya
30 % de décès 90% des cas sont des
réactions médicamenteuse certains
peuvent être liés à une infection à
mycoplasme mais sinon pour le reste on a
identifié à ce jour une douzaine de
molécules un risque élevé de syndrome de
l'aïeul parmi lesquels les sulfamides
anti-infectieux certains anti
inflammatoire certains anti épileptiques
l'allopurinol et la névirapine il ya
bien sûr d'autres médicaments mais non
pas un risque
aussi élevé qui a été relevé c'est une
maladie orpheline ya 150 cas qui sont à
peu près 1 par an en france un millier
dans l'union européenne
c'est également une maladie chronique
95% des survivants garde des séquelles
invalidantes et évolutive qui bouleverse
leur vie et ça c'est quelque chose
d'assez récent on a eu du mal à
démontrer que les gens ne s'en sortait
pas indemme l'identification du
médicament est très difficile puisqu'il
ya un effet retard entre la prise et la
survenue de la réaction les moyens
donnés à la recherche sont très
insuffisants à ce jour tout comme la
prise en charge des séquelles qui est
quasi inexistante
sauf peut-être pour les séquelles les
plus graves qui sont les séquelles
oculaire mais beaucoup de traitements ne
sont pas pris en charge comme ça
concerne la peau les yeux les dents
souvent des domaines sont mal pris en
charge par la sécurité sociale
il faut savoir qu'il ya quelques années
en 2003 il ya un dispositif très
innovant qui est apparue et qu'il ya
permettait de changer radicalement la
vie des malades
il est victime ont dû payer pour mener
l'étude sur ce dispositif sur les verts
scléro afin de prouver leurs bénéfices
et d'obtenir la prise en charge par la
sécurité sociale
ce qui caractérise par rapport au
médiateur notamment ce type de réaction
c'est que c'est souvent un risque
accepté et que partant de là il n'y a
pas tellement de retombées médiatiques
pourtant il ya autant voire peut-être
plus de victimes que le médiator si on
fait le compte au total
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée que
vous connaissez bien sûr les quatre 4
dernières années
ça correspond à peu près 450 500
victimes avec un peu moins de 150 morts
et sur les 33 dernières années cid entre
3500 et 4000 victimes et environ 1000
1200 morts mais vous parlez enfonce en
france en france
et à ma liste a été créé en 2002 on est
agréé depuis 2007 on est une association
de patients et de victimes c'est à dire
qu'on essaye à la fois de lutter pour
une meilleure prise en charge pour la
recherche sur ces maladies et pour pour
l'indemnisation nos moyens nos
partenaires je dirais sont le centre
national maladies rares qui est située à
henri-mondor à créteil avec de nouveaux
nombreux centres affiliés en région et
un registre européen dans le copilote
est situé en france et qui fait
également des études épidémiologiques et
de la recherche
donc on essaye d'amener une vision
d'ensemble sur la gestion du risque
on travaille à la fois sur la recherche
la prise en charge et on aurait aimé
mais on n'y est pas arrivé à skis cette
gestion globale du risque puisse
intégrer en amont l'afssaps et en lavage
dire l oniam pour l'indemnisation des
victimes
il nous semble qu'une gestion du risque
correct devrait intégrer toute cette
toute cette chaîne mais ce n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui
je voudrais rapidement abordé deux
thèmes qui sont à la fois en liaison
avec le le contrôle et l'évaluation des
médicaments est aussi notre expérience
d'associations de victimes d'une part
une analyse très très rapide du système
de surveillance du risque tels que nous
on a pu en faire l'expérience au travers
de du syndrome de laguiole et notre
coopération avec l'afssaps
et puis en deuxième une deuxième point
qu'ils analysent la prise en charge du
risque notamment de l'indemnisation
globalement sur sur la surveillance du
risque et le système de
pharmacovigilance
il nous semble qu'un des points faibles
c'est que ce système ne repose pas sur
un système d'information décisionnel
c'est à dire que le système de
pharmacovigilance systèmes d'information
de la pharmacovigilance consiste à
comptabiliser en entrée la réalisation
des risques dont les effets indésirables
des médicaments notamment au travers de
la notification spontanée mais il n'est
pas en sortit un véritable outil de la
des stades aide à la décision et je
pense que se mettre en place un
véritable outil dallas décision fait
partie des grands enjeux de la
pharmacovigilance
avec aussi il faut le dire celui là sous
notification patente des effets
indésirables graves
donc aujourd'hui on a un système qui ne
permettent pas d'automatiser le
déclenchement des alertes puisque c'est
un peu le but de ce système c'est de
dire à un moment donné le risque est
plus acceptable donc on déclenche une
une réévaluation aujourd'hui il ya deux
façons de le faire c'est délà des cinq
ans la fin du délai de surveillance des
cinq ans soit sur décision du directeur
de l'afssaps et ces deux procédures ne
peuvent pas être efficaces parce que
d'une part le délai d des cinq ans est à
notre sens complètement artificielle le
temps n'est pas le critère pertinent
pour mesurer le risque d'un médicament
le critère pertinent c'est la population
qui est exposé à la substance active
pour la première fois et cette
population elle va s'estimer en fonction
du niveau de risque on cherche à
détecter et majoré évidemment du taux de
sous notification des médicaments par
exemple si on veut de détecter un risque
de un sur dix mille nouveaux
utilisateurs et qu'on suspecte ce risque
comme c'est le cas pour le laguiole
d'être notifiés seulement une fois sur
deux à la population pertinente
ces vingt mille personnes mais si c'est
une personne sur dix qui va faire un cas
sur 10 qui est remonté
ça va être sans huile etc
pour ce qui est de la décision du
directeur de l'afssaps on voit que c'est
pas très efficace aujourd'hui et pour
cause quand on a un portefeuille de 5000
molécules si on a pas derrière un
système d' aide à la décision qui vous
aident à générer automatiquement des
alertes c'est un petit peu difficile
d'avancer de façon efficace à notre sens
ce qui manque fondamentalement en amont
de la procédure pour générer ces alertes
c'est de fixer le lorsqu'on accepte un
risque quand on autorise la mise sur le
marché d'un médicament
c'est de fixer un niveau de risque
attendu c'était en quelque sorte un
seuil maximum d'acceptabilité du risque
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
quand on accepte un risque pour
l'acceptent quel que soit le niveau de
réalisation et nous va on a eu beaucoup
pas mal de surprises au niveau des
médicaments causant du laguiole parce
que finalement on a pas du tout de
visibilité sur à partir de quel moment
ce le risque est pas acceptable et plus
acceptable et à partir de quel moment
l'afssaps va réagir
je vais vous donner trois exemples qui
vont faire vous faire puissent
comprendre notre notre désarroi
en 2001 la saps a suspendu la mm des
sédatifs léger qui contenait du fait nos
barbes italie au motif que ces
médicaments avait un smr insuffisant et
qu'ils avaient en plus provoqué sur dix
ans une douzaine de cas de laguiole
s'ils avaient remonté douze cas ça veut
dire qu'elle n'avait au minimum 24 et le
médicament était son marché depuis 50
ans donc ça fait 100 facilement plus de
200 cas de laguiole duo phénobarbital
sur les 50 dernières années donc on se
demande pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fallu
attendre 2001 pour tout d'un coup se
dire tiens on va enlever ce médicament
du marché et à côté de ça en 2005
l'afssaps a ordonné le retrait des
immunostimulant aux motifs aussi d'un
smr insuffisant et d'effets indésirables
type crises d'asthme purpura oedème du
visage fièvre plus un cas douteux de
laguiole et ce cas douteux de laguiole a
suffi à ce qu'on retire ans le
médicament du marché alors une petite
anecdote entre guillemets amusante c'est
que la victime de ce syndrome de la yale
elle quand elle est allée devant l'oniam
pour obtenir l'indemnisation elle a été
déboutée fossati non votre cas
et douteux donc on est un peu une
machine à deux vitesses quand
l'administration veut servir de ce cas
pour enlever un médicament du marché
le doute bénéficie bénéficie
administration et quand il s'agit
d'indemniser la victime il bénéficie
toujours à l'indemnisation à
l'administration pardon mais pas la
victime ce qui est un peu regrettable
aujourd'hui on a un problème avec la
lamotrigine et l'allopurinol qui sont
les deux plus grands pourvoyeurs de
laguiole en europe
maintenant vous avez dit le premier
médicament c'est la lamotrigine
lamotrigine oui c'est un anti convient
le sens et c'était connu ce nom de
l'amicale avant que ce soit générique
est donc le lamotrigine en fait c'est un
médicament cathy mis en marché en 95
donc là après la fin de la période de
surveillance dans les années 2000 les
ventes ont explosé et le nombre de
victimes également et malgré ça en 2008
il ya une extension d'indication maladie
bipolaire mais c'est le deuxième
pourvoyeur de laguiole en europe crâne
il n'y a pas de plan de gestion de
risque et pareil pour l'allopurinol qui
a un médicament contre la goutte qui lui
doit avoir un problème de mésusage parce
qu'il doit être prescrit un peu deux
fois plus que la prévalence connu de la
goutte et c'est le premier pourvoyeur de
laguiole et là non plus pas de plan de
gestion de risque donc on n'a pas trop
de visite figure pas dans la liste de
ceux dont on n'a pas de visibilité sur
c'est quoi le niveau maximum de risque
acceptable et partant de là on doute
qu'on puisse construire un système
d'information pertinents pour ce qui est
du problème de l'indemnisation
nous pensons à ma liste de ce que nous
pouvons voir que l'oniam est en train de
devenir une une compilation de fonds
spécifiques créés à la va vite au gré
des diverses crises sanitaires
oui le fonds d'indemnisation des
victimes par transfusion d
par transfusion donc victime pour
dévider virus hiv hépatite c le fonds
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
vaccination obligatoire
le fonds d'indemnisation des irradiés
d'epinal et maintenant on parle de créer
un fonds d'indemnisation spécifique pour
les victimes du médiator
donc le risque c'est que dans 20 ans
lanning l'oniam soit plus qu'un chapelet
de fonds d'indemnisation personne n'y
comprendra plus rien qui sera une
véritable usine à gaz
et nous on pense qu'il faut sortir de
cette impasse par le haut que les crises
sanitaires ne doivent pas conduire à ce
que les victimes parce qu'elles ont les
honneurs de la presse sont mieux traités
que toutes les autres victimes des
médicaments mais qu'au contraire ce
scandale du médiator doit être
l'occasion pour les politiques de mettre
en oeuvre une gestion globale du risque
médicamenteux quel qu'il soit alors
pourquoi je parle du risques
médicamenteux dans son ensemble parce
que le médicament est un produit à
risque
on n'arrête pas de le dire depuis déjà
quelques mois mais que le modèle qui
préside à son acceptabilité pose
problème en fait on pense qu'il est un
peu inachevé aujourd'hui ce modèle s'est
il encadrer par la notion de de balance
bénéfices risques est ce modèle en fait
pose que le illégitime l'idée qu'on
puisse sacrifier une minorité pour le
bien-être du plus grand nombre et c'est
quelque chose qui nous paraît tout à
fait défendable et que même nous
victimes des médicaments on accepte
complètement
par contre ce que nous n'acceptons pas
c'est que cette inégalité ne soit pas
réparé dès le début c'est qu'on ne pose
pas dès le début que ce risque doit être
indemnisées parce que quand il ya une
majorité de deux citoyens qui vont
bénéficier bénéficier du risque du
médicament dû bénéficier du médicament
parce que c'est un progrès social mais
qu'il y a à côté peut-être deux ou trois
personnes pour et thérapeutique c'est un
vrai ce sont des vrais progrès mais à
côté de ça il ya toujours deux ou trois
personnes qui vont subir des accidents
des effets indésirables très très grave
donc il faut il faut réparer ça
à la base ce qui n'a pas été pensée en
fait par le le régulateur à l'eau à
l'origine donc en fait la situation
aujourd'hui qu'elle est près de là ça
n'a pas été pensée donc ça n'a pas été
pensé mais il semblerait que c'est
pratiquement jamais indemnisées puisque
c'est en présentant nos gammes c'est ce
que vous aviez dit oui bon je vais vous
décrire la situation en fait aujourd'hui
où en fait on part d'une situation où le
risque de fait n'est pas du tout pensé
comme un risque assurable est
indemnisable et il faut savoir que
depuis depuis 88 le moment où la
directive sur les produits défectueux
aurait dû être transposée en france
le juge considère que si le risque est
marqué dans la notice on a ce qu'on
appelle un risque légitime et que ça ne
doit pas donner lieu ce n'est pas un
produit défectueux
ça doit pas donner lieu à indemnisation
donc on a pu noble ication de sécurité
absolue mais c'est une obligation de
sécurité relative et la notice devient
en quelque sorte un parapluie juridique
pour les laboratoires qui sont
complètement déresponsabiliser du risque
de la faute mais aussi du riste dans son
ensemble donc ça c'est pour les vitres
concerne particulièrement les victimes
en 4 88 et 2001 qui n'ont aucune chance
de recours pour ce qui est de l'oniam
on a bien vu qu'elle ne résolvait pas du
tout le problème des accidents
médicamenteux puisque ça doit
représenter 2 % des dossiers à peu près
en fait l'oniam a résolu pas mal de
problématique
effectivement en créant de la notion de
fins de solidarité nationale mais elle a
pas résolu le problème de la charge de
la preuve qui est très spécifique dans
le cas des accidents médicamenteux
en fait l'imputabilité d'une réaction un
principe actif ne peut pas être
démontrée sur le plan individuel et
c'est ce qu'on voudrait demander aux
victimes
pourtant je suis un faire remarquer que
quand on autorise la mise sur le marché
d'un médicament
on doit prouver le bénéfice et le risque
et c'est toujours sur un plan
statistique parce qu'on sait que c'est
absolument pas possible au niveau
individuel
donc il faut accepter qu'une
démonstration qu'ils soient faits sur le
plan statistique
sachant que même sur le plan statistique
c'est pas forcément très évident parce
que aujourd'hui par exemple avec des
études cas-témoins on peut faire
ressortir que des niveaux de risque
élevé donc aujourd'hui on connaît les
molécules à risque très élevé mais
celles qui ont un risque moins élevée
ont peut pas le démontrer de façon
formelle pourtant on sait que ce sont
des accidents des accidents
médicamenteux ça on peut le démontrer
nous nous en fait on a des propositions
qui sont très simples on pense que je
vais voter parce que bon pour que tout
le monde puisse intervenir faut pas que
les interventions des pinceaux 10 15
minutes là vous en êtes à à 10 12
donc pour les propositions vous m'avez
fait parvenir un document que je et on
va le mettre à la disposition de la
mission parce que je suis déçu à titre
personnel qui est un document qui est
très bien fait alors compte tenu du fait
que on va pouvoir en disposer peut-être
pouvez-vous resserré votre intervention
concernant les propositions
oui je voulais juste résumer en trois
points il nous paraît important que le
risque d'effets indésirables surtout
lorsqu'il est spécifié dans la notice
soit assurée donc il doit y avoir pour
nous il doit y avoir une obligation
d'assurance pour le producteur
en clair quelle que soit la forme
d'assurance choisi un soleil passe par
des assureurs soit il est son propre
assureur
mais le coût du risque doit être
intégrée au final dans le cou de
médicaments
et sachant qu'il sera répercutée de
toute façon sur le payeur final la
sécurité sociale ça changera pas
tellement le modèle économique des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques
mais par contre ça apportera une vraie
réponse un énorme problème sociétal le
fait que le riz soit mentionnés dans la
notice doit constituer une présomption
de preuves pour la victime et sept
mentions doit oublier aussi se traduire
pour le producteur par une obligation de
mettre en place un vrai plan de gestion
de risques parce qu'on trouve
actuellement
merci merci je vais donc passer
maintenant la parole à monsieur gérard
raymond président de l'association
française des diabétiques monsieur le
président vous savez là l'association
française avait tiqué la première
association de patients pour défendre et
représenter l'ensemble de la communauté
des patients diabétiques
effectivement nous sommes retrouvés en
première ligne dans cette affaire là du
médiator parce que le premier abord ce
médicament avait été prescrit à
l'ensemble de la communauté des patients
avec de type 2 en fait pour s'avérer que
finalement simplement ce médicament a
été beaucoup plus prescrits à des non
diabétiques les diabétiques 4 mm on va
pas refaire l'histoire
l'association française à meetic s'est
essentiellement consacré sur trois axes
à partir du moment où cette affaire-là
éclaté réclamé le recensement de toutes
les personnes qui ont consommé du
médiator leur assurer au moins un examen
afin de de considérer le risque
d'anxiété et que effectivement c'est
excellent là soient pris en charge à
100% de la communauté cette première
revendication a été assurée est fait
puisque
nous avons travaillé avec l'afssaps et
l'assurance maladie à la rédaction de de
plus de 6 à mille courriers pour envoyer
à tous les patients qui ont pris du
médiator est encore encore actuellement
nous travaillons avec l'assurance
maladie pour essayer de retrouver les
patients jusqu'en 2006 et l'état à
assurer la garantie à 100% de ces
examens delà de toutes ces personnes
notre deuxième axe a été effectivement
de pouvoir indemniser les personnes
considérées victimes du médiator
et cela dans le cadre de fondane
canalisations publiques regroupant
l'ensemble des responsables et le
rapport de l'igas
si la pointe est effectivement que le
laboratoire servier portait une très
très large part de responsabilité
l'état avait aussi sa responsabilité en
tant qu'etat et puis peut-être d'autres
d'autres notamment les assurés de
prescripteurs qui auraient pu prescrire
noailles mais ce faux là nous le
réclamons le cadre l'onia même si je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que
vient de dire madame sur ce que
risquerait de devenir l'homme dame
aujourd'hui les difficultés de son
fonctionnement
y compris notamment sur la nécessité
aujourd'hui de revaloriser les aides
nationales ont mis à main qui sont
depuis 2002 2004 n'ont jamais été
revalorisée et nous avons fait plusieurs
propositions
la dernière a été une proposition de loi
un conte a déposé jeudi dernier à
l'assemblée nationale avec le collectif
était associatif et d'autres
associations pour provoquer un petit peu
la création de ce fonds parce que nous
considérons qu effectivement depuis
maintenant c'est moi
on a eu je les dis d'une façon un peu
provocante mais on a eu beaucoup
d'effets de manche mais n'a pas eu
beaucoup d'action au niveau 2 au niveau
de la responsabilité de l'état
il semblerait qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement nous rentrons dans une
phase un peu plus active un peu plus
concrète
sauf que pendant ce temps là nous avons
bien vu que y compris le laboratoire
servier et qui a fait les démarches et
directe auprès auprès de certains
patients y compris certains cabinets
d'avocats etc etc
on a bien vu connaissez mon franc parler
certains marchands du temple occuper le
terrain et profiter un petit peu delà de
la misère du désarroi des patients
d'autant plus qu' on peut que ne peut
que regretter qu effectivement dans la
foulée lara kerry de l'afssaps en
publiant les 77 la liste des 77 n'a fait
que augmenter la méfiance et la défiance
des patients des amis du système ceux
qui à un moment donné et certainement
pas une bonne solution pour retrouver la
confiance de l'ensemble du système
donc sur ce fond de même bien sûr mais
nous avons déposé la loi on peut on
pourra reparler si vous vous leviez il
est bien évident que nous considérons
que javier devrait l'amendé qu'il doit
être gérée d'une façon tout à fait
indépendante et que la commission des
experts loi a assuré et les critères et
les taux des vins bien mérité que je
vous accuse parce que effectivement
servier c'est un philanthrope où la
marque est donc si vous voulez attendre
que servier y contribue au financement
de ce fonds je pense qu on risque
d'attendre longtemps surtout si on veut
que ce financement suffisant donc ouais
je je pense que
il serait beaucoup plus je dirais
astucieux 1,2 de faire en sorte que ce
soit l'état qui avancent et que l'état
se retourne contre servier pour ensuite
peut-être obtenir ce que vous un par un
vous n'arrivez pas obtenir enfin c'est
une main non non mais c'est une
suggestion enfin et vient pas de moi
c'est l'audition dieu sait que choisit
arrière qui m'a dit ma mère qui m'a
apporté cette idée avec laquelle je
pense qu'ils me paraît intéressante je
pense que nous aurons certaines
informations assez de temps là-dessus
il est bien évident que dans le cadre du
comité de suivi du médiator que nous
participons c'est dans ce que cette
direction l'accent devrait se diriger le
gouvernement et nous attendons
incessamment sous peu une information à
ce sujet mais nous avons voulu aller
plus loin de toute façon il faudra un
cadre une loi pour encadrer ce fonds
c'est très clair et assez rapidement
nous nous le demandons avec avec force
et le troisième axe de notre de notre
action a été effectivement la refonte de
notre système de pharmacovigilance et
les bienvenus dans que on s'est bien
rendu compte que aujourd'hui à vouloir
ne considérer que l' expertise
scientifique et l'industrie
pharmaceutique
nous avons fonctionner en vase clos en
consanguinité
tout cela a engendré tout au moins
certains certaines dérives
nous considérons qu effectivement il
nous faut reconsidérer l'expertisé
profane l'intégrer dans l'ensemble de
notre
je suivi de pharmacovigilance je tenais
juste à vous dire que par exemple la
commission de transparence de la haute
autorité de santé ne comporte pas
l'association de passionnés le patient
c'est quand même même si donc il a
certainement effectivement une refonte
totale et les assises du médicament
aujourd'hui en discussions devraient
reprendre à peu près refondre le système
mais pour nous ce qui est important
c'est que reconnaître effectivement le
rôle des associations de patients leur
expertise profane lanta mule la
spécificité de chacun d'entre nous y
compris toutes les associations allons à
leur propre domaine pouvoir être nous
aussi de donner l alerte pour les effets
secondaires
à ce sujet d'ailleurs nous avons nous
mêmes alertés il y à peu l'assurance
maladie que nous considérons aujourd'hui
et comme étant peut-être la seule
institution peu stable pour le moment
ayant des données scientifiques assez
importante et nous avons demandé à
l'assurance maladie
y compris à l'afssaps et à la haute
autorité de santé
mais pourquoi pas de faire une enquête
sur les dernières molécules qui sont
sortis pour le traitement des
diabétiques de type 2 cela nous paraît
important que dès la sortie des deux
molécules ne laisse pas simplement
laboratoire d'étude mais aussi vous
pensez au dos à la pioglitazone par
exemple rats je pense au dpp 4 décrypte
ineo j'ai loupé un d'accord mais
effectivement est donc conscient que dès
la mise sur le marché d'une molécule
j'aurais que l'institution prenne une
cohorte de patients la suivent notamment
sur les effets secondaires
et puis pour ne pas revenir à la
dramatique affaire avec qui et le
médiator donc sur ces trois points
effectivement sur le sur le recensement
et le suivi de cohortes de patients nous
avons obtenu satisfaction nous attendons
effectivement ce fonds d'indemnisation
dans le cas de l'oniam avec
une gestion indépendante et c'est vrai
que le risque de l'audience avec eux un
pyromane de faune il faudra bien aussi
que le législateur prenne un petit peu
et des poussières ce que le sucre
l'oniam est enfin sur le troisième point
donc la refonte de notre système le
maroc au liban nous travaillons dans le
cadre des assises du médicament et nous
espérons qu effectivement nous aurons là
véritablement un système transparent
reconnaissant l'expertisé profane des
patients merci monsieur raymond monsieur
dominique michel courtois vous avez la
parole oui je vous remercie monsieur le
président de nous avoir convié à ce
débat note l'association est un peu
spécifique c'est à dire c'est qu'une
association qui a été créée en 2001 et
qui s'est occupé dans un premier temps
de l'isoméride puisqu'on avait à peu
près 500 patients malheureusement à
l'époque les médias s'étaient emparés de
la faire et on a donc engagé des
procédures individuelles contre
laboratoires servier avec beaucoup de
problèmes s'il ya des problèmes
financiers puisqu'il fallait pour chaque
cas engager une procédure devant le tgi
de nanterre avec des frais d'avocat plus
ou moins mais surtout des frais d'
expertise et c'était des expertises avec
trois experts qui est dépassé les 5000
euros donc peu de gens engagé des
procédures il y en a encore en cours
effectivement laboratoire servier a
utilisé tous les moyens que l'on connaît
même d'autres pour manifestement
torpiller les expertises ou décider les
personnes arrêtées néanmoins il ya eu
plusieurs jugements il y en a eu h pas
si vous l'avez vu récemment au mois de
février
on a obtenu la condamnation des
laboratoires servier joie 180000 euros
ce sabre une personne malheureusement
des cv mais après sept ans de procédure
puisque on est allé en cassation ont
failli la vente hors servier utilise
toutes les possibilités juridiques qui
sont à leur disposition et depuis au
cours de l'année dernière on a vu
arriver des victimes du médiator
mais fort de ce qui s'était passé pour
l'isoméride j'ai dit
dans un premier temps attendons parce
que si on repart contre les laboratoires
servier dans les mêmes conditions
je pense qu'on aura peut-être les mêmes
résultats donc on a entendu un petit peu
puis c'est passé
heureusement ce qui s'est passé avec
irène frachon avec pas mal de
publication et donc la sphère du
médiator est arrivé
donc effectivement on était tout désigné
pour s'occuper en même temps que
l'isoméride et je sais pas si vous avez
vu on a faim on a pensé qu'il fallait
peut-être vis-à-vis de servi avoir une
action forte dans un premier temps même
s'ils ont négocié seconde herman la mise
en place d'un fonds et donc qu'on a
déposé six cent cinquante plaintes au
pôle de santé publique du tgi de paris
pour homicide involontaire pour
blessures involontaires une centaine je
crois pour tromperie j'ai été reçue par
les trois juges d'instruction puisque
l'association s'est portée partie civile
partie civile dans les différentes au
mi6 de blessure et tromperies et
malheureusement ces trois juge pascal
gand anne marie bellot et patrick vieira
m'ont expliqué qu'il y aurait ce qui
était normal d'ailleurs dans le pénal
une expertise médicale pour chaque
individu ce qui veut dire ça plus le
reste effectivement au pénal on est
parti pour des années j'espère pas des
dizaines d'années même si la volonté
politique est d'aller lite je pense que
la justice dira beaucoup moins et donc
c'est vrai qu'on s'est tourné un petit
peu vers la négociation via les le
comité de suivi des victimes du
benfluorex et madame hélène fabre pour
justement elle négociait laboratoires
servier car le but c'était d'essayer
d'obtenir quand même le maximum du
laboratoire sachant que jusqu'à
aujourd'hui ou hier ce qu'il proposait
était totalement inacceptable de toute
manière donc c'est ce qu'a ce qui a été
fait et ce que j'ai demandé depuis
toujours c'est un fonds d'indemnisation
gouvernementale qui prendra en charge la
totalité des victimes et jeudi un peu en
boutade à la limite en tant que
président de l'association le
financement c'est pas notre problème
c'est à dire que que ça soit servier que
ce soit l'état que ce soit l'état tout
seul ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il ya des
victimes alors on sait pas trop combien
de milliers mais ça sera sûrement des
milliers ou des dizaines de milliers
effectivement il faudra répondre à cette
demande et je crois que c'est dans ce
sens que l'on va en ce qui concerne les
différentes réformes je crois que déjà
vous en avez tous parlé moi ce que je
crois c'est tôt aux donneurs d'alerté je
pense qu'on devrait associer les
patients beaucoup plus qu'on ne l'a fait
jusqu'à aujourd'hui en les motivant en
leur expliquant ce qui peut survenir des
complications des médicaments et je
pense que les patients les médecins
généralistes devraient être si vous
voulez les premiers témoins de ces
dysfonctionnements qu'il faudrait
ensuite faire remonter en espérant qu'au
niveau supérieur on est des instances
qui soit capable de réagir dans des
conditions plus efficace que celle qu'on
l'a vu et pour le médiator et parce que
je m'en occupe aussi les prothèses
mammaires pip et qui intéresse trente
mille personnes et où à l'époque
l'afssaps avertissez un mois al avance
des soi-disant contrôles inopinés qu'ils
allaient faire donc ça leur permettait
pendant un mois de mettre de côté le gel
frauduleux et quand l'absence arrivé
tout était beau donc là aussi je pense
qu'il faudra y remédier alors ça
effectivement ça c'est un autre problème
oui mais enfin c'est scellier sont les
dispositifs médicaux alors on en parlera
un petit peu mais ça constitue pas
l'essentiel de l'enquète de notre
mission mais cette vous avez raison de
le signaler c'est très important
il est surprenant que le tout ce qui est
matériel implantable jusqu'à aujourd'hui
une fois qu'ils avaient obtenu
l'autorisation il n'y a pas de contrôles
systématiques et en plus ces délégués
assis dans ces pays paie à une société
allemande
vous avez terminé sur ims et je vous
remercie infiniment monsieur félicie
félicite
la parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice de nous recevoir ce
matin bien la fnath je pense qu'on n'a
pas besoin de présenter fête ses 90 ans
cette année
après cent cinquante mille adhérents et
fédère plusieurs autres associations
dont l'association des ce dont on parle
peu ce qui est regrettable qui est
l'association des victimes du distilbène
oui et si vous permettez monsieur le
président sans vous paraître indélicat
ou grossier je formulerai le souhait
qu'elle soit aussi reçu parce que je
crois qu'elle n'a été reçue par aucune
aucun des parlementaires et hauts en
audition d'accord ça nous permettrait de
voir et je rejoins ce que dit madame le
pallec que vous êtes ici devant un choix
politique au plus haut sens le plus
noble du terme c'est à dire que pour
l'instant
évidemment il ya beaucoup de bruit parce
que ceux qui sont plus ou moins
responsable de façon directe ou
indirecte font le plus de bruit possible
pour qu'on ne se préoccupe pas trop des
responsabilités de chacun mais là vous
avez un choix à faire politique soit
vous vous servez de la sphère du
médiator comme levier pour améliorer la
globalité du système et essayer de
l'améliorer de façon définitive si tant
est qu'on puisse améliorer les choses de
façon définitive soit vous répondez à la
sphère du médiator avec une réponse
circonscrite en créant un fonds
d'indemnisation et basta qui sera
confiant non elle à l'oniam passez moi
cette expression et puis on s'arrêtera
là
voilà évidemment sûr c'est pas neutre
non mais je vous accuse de prêter au jeu
jeudi que nous on estime à la fnath
parce que la fnath c'est quoi c'est
aussi vous le savez mieux mieux qu'eux
aussi bien que nous puisque vous avez
dans cette maison et et on vous doit
beaucoup de choses dans cette maison
vous avez eu à vous préoccuper des
victimes de l'amiante et vous qui avez
cette expérience des victimes de
l'amiante
vous retrouvez les finalement les mêmes
stigmates dans cette affaire du médiator
une responsabilité évidente de l'état
avec des carences qui est des carences
inacceptables qui sont proches passez
moi l'expression mais d'une république
bananière
parce que quand on a des victimes qui
vous signale
des choses quand on a des effets
indésirables qui sont signalés et que ça
dort dans les tiroirs d'une agence
sanitaire de l'état je me demande si
nous sommes en france tu pas si
l'adjectif est quand même un petit peu
excessif
oui sans doute mais ça va ça va bien de
forcer le trait en ce moment sur cette
question parce que il ya je pense qu'il
faut quand même remettre les choses et
voir l'ampleur du problème parce qu'il
n'ya pas que le médiator
on a eu l'amiante on a eu le sang
contaminé on allait des victimes dont
parle madame le pallec on a eu avant
l'isoméride
on a ces affaires de prothèses on a les
victimes du death l'avandia ya la
cérivastatine ont donc c'est bien c'est
bien systémique c'est pas la sphère du
médiator donc nous nous considérons
qu'il faut donner une réponse globale
parce que manifestement dans ce pays
à travers ces crises la sécurité c'est
pas c'est excessif ce que je dis je le
sais bien un mais la sécurité des
personnes n'est pas réellement assurée
en termes sanitaires sanitaire salutaire
u8 la sécurité sanitaire
on a hier j'entendais à la radio une
proposition de loi faite par un collègue
surtout les effets indésirables causés
notamment par les plastiques ça aussi on
en parle sont pas des choses nouvelles
on est toujours dans la même logique qu
est ce qu on a quoi on à l'intérêt
économique qui est mis en avant pour
surtout ne rien toucher
on a des agences sanitaires qui disent
oui il ya peut-être quelque chose
effectivement n'en ai entendu parler que
mais il faut qu'on fasse encore des
études et on a d'autres notamment
certains industriels pas tous parce que
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
dévolution sur ce sujet qui vous disent
ou qu'ils nous disent où d'autres comme
pour l'amiante comme pour vous comme
pour le death comme pour tous les autres
mais où sont vos victimes
il n'y a pas de victime donc nous on
veut bien mais il n'y a pas de victime
donc vous avez toujours les mêmes
stigmates sur ces différentes affaires
donc nous ce pour quoi nous plaidons
aujourd'hui c'est un changement
systémique réellement avec en ce qui
concerne cette affaire du médiator
posait la question du médicament du
médicament en tant que tel
alors si on fait une loi sur
l'indemnisation des victimes du médiator
ça fera comme l'a dit je sais plus qui
je crois que c'est madame une tranche de
plus dans le mille feuilles et en 2025
on aura un oniam qui aura 127 fonds pour
127 scandale différents à votre guise
si on prend le sujet globalement je
pense qu'il ya trois axes dans une loi
qui pourrait d'ailleurs être une mois de
restauration de la confiance dans le
médicament parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
bien ça aujourd'hui vous avez on a fait
un rapport il ya cinq ans oui et qu'est
ce qu'il est devenu immortel science
oui c'est pour ça que je dis cela c'est
pour ça que oui alors c'est à dire que
nos propositions n'ont pas été pris
avant la sidération pas voilà et
pourquoi poser la question monsieur
bertrand puisque il était je crois c'est
pas la personne de monsieur bertrand ou
d'un autre et du ministre du budget mis
en place avait pas mais mais voilà la
substantifique moelle de cette affaire
allait là alors que des rapports je veux
dire là on a l'impression de découvrir
l'eau chaude avec la sphère du médiator
tout ça c'est connu vous avez des
tripotées de victimes et d'associations
qui vous diront tout la même chose voilà
comment ça s'est passé donc les
dispositions là nous on pense qu'il ya
effectivement parce que on a une longue
expérience de ces affaires là avec
l'amiante vous savez ça ça nous a quand
même un peu bouleversé que l'état
français acceptent que celui qui a causé
le préjudice dicte ses conditions
d'indemnisation rendez compte à quel
point nous sommes arrivés et pas
quelqu'un qui est capable de 2 c'est
comme si nous victimes de l'amiante on
nous aurait demandé de négocier avec
eternit en disant bas voyez avec eternit
peut-être qu'ils ternissent va accepter
de vous payer un bout de la chose on
sait pas négocié avec eux nous on
regarde donc voilà
sur le fond nous a évidemment trois axes
il ya un la prévention c'est à dire
améliorer le système en tant que tel bon
alors il ya plusieurs propositions qui
sont faites vous allez recevoir j'ai vu
dans l'après-midi ou 7 et hier je ne me
souviens plus monsieur etienne caniard
de la muqueuse
c'était hier c'était hier de la
mutualité française gg j'ai vu et j'ai
longuement pris connaissance des deux du
des propositions des dix propositions
est effectivement elles sont
remarquables nous là dessus on a pas de
sujets majeurs j'ose dire si il était
adopté
et quand je dis adopter si ça suivait
derrière parce que il faut encore que
les décrets d'application sorte
non il faut d'abord on peut le proposer
mais il n'est pas c'est pas parce qu'on
le propose on a oui il sera un peu filer
donc moi aussi si vous voulez si si il
fit si vous nous adopter la moitié des
propositions qui sont écrites dans les
propositions de la mutualité où ça me va
très bien je te rendes que la moitié
ayant un esprit pragmatique et le sens
du réel
en revanche ce que je pense c'est que
j'ai deux sentiments là dessus le
premier c'est le suivant la question les
tout bête est souvent souvent combien on
a deux bataillons à mettre dans sa
sphère on est là en ce moment à chappes
et vous savez mieux que nous à chaque
projet de loi de finances ou de
financement de la sécurité sociale
à se demander comment on va rentrer dans
les cadres pour pas perdre en gros la
note triple a et est là ouais
combien de bataillon nous avons un
maître parce que qu'est-ce vous
l'attendez par l'eba tête mais quel est
le budget qui va être réservé cette
réforme
ah oui parce que c'est ça le problème a
oui le problème il est là on a en face
de nous joue le jeu joe force le trait
mais à titre anecdotique 18 mille
visiteurs médicaux
combien en at personnes à mettre en
place de quelques elles vont être lequel
va être le budget de cette agence
comment comment on va faire toutes ces
questions sont des vraies questions mon
avis quand on aborde ces raisons donc
partant de là et j'essaierai d'aller
rapidement donc c'est la question du nom
de bataillon de l'autre côté je crois
que y manque dans ce système quand même
une véritable alors vous parlez des
plaintes au pénal
bon alors c'est très bien les plaintes
au pénal ça fait beaucoup de bruit les
journalistes adorent ces superbes nous
ça fait 20 ans qu'on a déposé une
plainte au pénal pour la faire de
l'amiante
les veuves ça fait 20 ans qu'ils
attendent qu'elle a plein la plainte
sortent donc
donc si vous voulez nous je pense qu'il
nous manque alors pourquoi pas imaginer
aussi une espèce de deux corps
indépendant qui serait chargé
effectivement d'un corps complètement
indépendant leur peut-être type
inspecteurs igas pour le médicament qui
serait à la fois et je pense que
l'important c'est ça on a là mêmes et on
a ce qui se passe après et après il faut
effectivement tout le monde est d'accord
là dessus une surveillance constante et
régulière effectuées par des gens je
suis désolé c'est une prérogative de
puissance publique qui ne peuvent avoir
aucun lien avec une quelconque
industries qui sont à mon sens qui
devrait être des fonctionnaires d'état
et jeu c'est pour ça que je pense aux
inspecteurs de l'igas une sorte de deux
pas de police du médicament parce que ça
pourrait faire sourire et pas et penser
à ça naïf mais on a vous l'avez dit 5600
parle de police sanitaire c'est un terme
administratif de droit administratif
mais en termes de donc de la police du
médicament ça me paraît un corps
spécialisé de fonctionnaires qui ne
ferait donc dans le métier serait de
contrôler la vie du médicament et ses
effets indésirables
vous pouvez garder des agences mais on
aurait un corps spécifiques
moi je on a cinq mille molécules là moi
je pensais par exemple aussi on peut on
peut tout imaginer on est ici pour
livrer des réflexions et on vous fera
nos propositions écrites quand la loi
sortira mais vous avez quelque chose qui
fonctionne aussi c'est la cellule
tracfin par exemple il ya des choses
comme ça à penser ailleurs que dans le
médicament
en tout état de cause il faut des gens
qui soient capables d'exploiter des
choses qui existent déjà
on a des serres pb qui fonctionne très
bien
parce que l'eure l'eure l'eure l'eure le
nombre d'agents a été augmentée mais on
a des choses qui existent déjà on a eu
nos mines et on le sait tous ce sont les
bases de données de la cnam
vous avez vu la rapidité avec laquelle
et l'objectivité avec laquelle une fois
qu'on a demandé à la cnam de vérifier
entre les gens qui avaient pris du
médiator et quelques années après qui
avait subi une hospitalisation ils ont
tout de suite sorti les choses et de
façon imparable il ya là une mine
extraordinaire de renseignement
seulement on va pas demandé à la cnam de
faire le boulot des autres parce qu'en
termes de responsabilités à peux pas
l'accepter
ça va pas devenir une agence sanitaire
bis en revanche on peut avoir un corps
d'inspecteurs et notamment
d'épidémiologistes attaché au palis
hainneville alien vs qui vont exploiter
pour chacune des molécules ou
régulièrement les bases de données et
travailler et là dessus je suis sûr
qu'on aura des choses donc ça pour nous
c'est quelque chose d'assez important
sur le reste je vous dis c'est cette
idée d'avoir un corps indépendant
incorruptibles s'il s'agit pas de
corruption d'ailleurs dans staff dans
cette affaire mais il s'agit de porosité
de on a bien vu que c'est pas possible
que des signalements reste dans des
tiroirs on a vu dans le rapport de
l'igas et je veux dire un scénariste de
los angeles où d'hollywood aurait pas
fait mieux que le rapport de l'igas
c'est extraordinaire je veux dire
n'importe quel film qu'on a pu voir avec
les vedettes américaines
le rapport de l'iga jdir il nous
l'achète à hollywood un une voiture bon
scénario
c'est magnifique et puis on a tous en c1
un vrai beau scénario et vaut mieux en
rire qu'en pleurer ensuite si oui c'est
pour ça que je vous dis stop
ensuite on a un point 2 quel point de
l'indemnisation
moi je pense qu'on pourra pas évoluer
sur la prévention en l'espèce du
médicament si on n'évolue pas
définitivement sur l'histoire de
l'indemnisation on a développé ce point
là la dernière fois l'audition
l'assemblée nationale avec madame le
pallec l'idée est la suivante vous avez
vous dans cette maison un honorable
sénateur qui a voté une loi fondamentale
en 85 sur les accidents de la route
monsieur le sénateur badinter l'idée
était la suivante dans un carambolage
vous avez vingt ou trente véhicules
d'impliquer il vous sera impossible
quand vous êtes une victime d'arriver à
prouver qui vous a causé le dommage
alors plutôt que de faire dix ans ou 15
ans procédure ou sept ans de procédure
avec des expertises des
contre-expertises devant des gens qui
ont tant qu'ils ont l'argent pour faire
de la procédure
l'idée qu'a été posée par la loi
badinter ces deux au lieu de dire on va
rechercher la cause
on va dire moi je me fiche de la cause à
partir du moment où un véhicule
terrestre moteur est impliqué impliqué
le responsable doit payer qu'ils
s'assurent qu'ils deviennent solvable ça
c'est un autre problème
mais on ne recherche plus la cause quand
vous remonter un peu cette affaire
puisque vous allez me et vous allez
peut-être en train de vous dire ce type
est complètement fou pour quoi il parle
de voiture alors qu'on a une audition
sur médicaments quand vous remontez la
chose la voiture et le présente
exactement les mêmes stigmates que cette
affaire quand vous prenez un peu de haut
la voiture est un élément de progrès
incontestable pour notre société
elle pourrait elle a un poids économique
qui est pas contestable avec une
problématique liée aux en pas remboursés
par la sécurité sociale
oui mais
ce oui mais il ya une obligation
d'assurance il ya une obligation
d'assurance qui solvabilise les victimes
d'accord mais la voiture en tant que tel
avec les progrès qu'elle a créé avec les
emplois qu'elles créent la richesse
économique qu'elle produit elle crée un
risque social évident et c'est
exactement la même affaire pour la santé
au travail on l'a dit à partir du moment
où la loi de 1898 a été votée et que on
avait dégagé le problème de la causalité
partir du moment où vous êtes sur votre
lieu de travail autant lieu de travail
l'employeur est responsable et les
employeurs entre e.on mutualiser les
risques pour s'assurer entre eux voilà
dans l'assurance automobile il ya une
mutualisation des risques tout le monde
paye pour les autres à partir du moment
où vous posez cette organisation-là le
secteur s'auto organisent aussi pour
faire la prévention
parce que moi je vais pas aller payer
pour les les carences de l'autre donc il
va falloir qu'on améliore les choses
donc ça pour nous c'est une pierre
fondamentale et on le voit c'est ce qui
est dit ici il ya des victimes qui sont
pas indemnisés il ya des victimes qui
passent dix ans de procédure donc en
gros
quelle est la réponse si c'est un
problème de causalité si on n'arrive pas
à déterminer
on n'a qu'à shunter la causalité comme
on l'a déjà fait sur d'autres sujets
sociétaux important le travail la
voiture moi je pense qu'il serait
intéressant aussi d'interroger
votre collègue badinter sur cette
question parce que je pense qu'il a eu
les mêmes problèmes à résoudre terme de
causalité que c'est un risque social
important qui avaient énormément mort
énormément de blessés encore aujourd'hui
mais saches sa chute et quand on
socialise un risque par une entreprise
d'assurance privée au d'état quant aux
socialistes un risque ce risque
socialiser mutualisé va être un
accélérateur de prévention c'est clair
personne aujourd'hui ne peut prétendre
que le fait que le risque a été autant
socialisant 85 n'est pas aussi
contribuer à la prévention
personne ne peut prétendre que la
branche at mp aujourd'hui réunissant
tous les employeurs ne contribue pas la
prévention donc ça c'est un deuxième axe
pour nous qui est de dire admettons
l'idée que le médicament est un est un
progrès considérable qu'on a des
entreprises qui sont quand même parmi
les meilleurs du monde
on doit préserver nos emplois absolument
en france ça mais pour ça il faut la
confiance dans le médicament et il faut
alors que eux acceptent de dire
effectivement ça crée un risque
effectivement on ne veut plus voir ces
scandales arriver donc on accepte l'idée
que le médicament créant un risque
implique comme s'occupe pas de la
causalité et qui a une responsabilité
qu'ils soient mutualisés entre nous
voilà l'idée si vous faites ça c'est un
pas de géant qui sera fait si on reste
sur la création d'une tranche
supplémentaire dans le mille feuilles on
aura fait un petit saut de puce ensuite
ensuite le point 3 de 2,2 de ce projet
qui pourrait être un projet de réforme
le point 3 me paraît quand même aussi
fondamental c'est on a un problème dans
dans ce pays sur la politique pénale des
de la criminalité sanitaire dire on a
déjà un système judiciaire dont on
connaît les difficultés et on à monsieur
vous le disais un pôle de santé publique
ça c'est déjà un progrès mais est-ce
qu'on a réellement une politique pénale
de la santé publique
est ce qu'on se dit que il faut avoir
une appréhension de là il faut avoir une
véritable politique pénale de la santé
publique et de se dire effectivement ce
qui dépasse les bornes
et alors là attention qu'on soit bien
clair un pour nous on met pas tout le
monde dans le même sac
il s'agit pas de tout mélanger mais ce
qui dépasse les bornes
donne parce que à la limite les
personnes il ya des incriminations qui
existent mais pour les grands groupes
qu'est ce qu'on a comme incrimination
pénale je vous dis même le rat dans jade
des sanctions financières qui sont
pressés pilote sépare du temps elles
sont rarement mis en oeuvre souvent ce
qui concerne la publicité ça voilà donc
fait donc on verrait un sujet là dessus
voilà et ensuite va j'en terminerai là
sur l'indemnisation je crois que gérard
vraiment a dit l'essentiel nous aussi
c'est à dire que il faut aussi profiter
de cette affaire du médiator pour revoir
les barèmes d'année le barème
d'indemnisation de l'oniam où il est
évident que quand vous le comparez à
certaines enfin à la majorité des
décisions judiciaires le barème est pas
suffisant donc si l'idée et je nous les
posons à la fnath
si l'idée c'est de dire on va créer un
fonds pour éviter effectivement la
judiciarisation et les victimes
r pendant des années dans les palais de
justice avant d'avoir une indemnisation
encore faut-il que l'indemnisation qui
soit prévu couvre tous les préjudices
comme le font les juridictions si vous
avez un prêt indemnisations
insuffisantes bas vous irez vous aurez
les gens qui vient et qui iront faire
des procédures parce que d'abord elles
seront démarchés pour aller faire ses
procédés en disant vas le fond vous
donne temps mais devant un juge vous
pouvez avoir plus à l'est devant du jeu
voilà dernier point qui nous semble
extrêmement important c'est le préjudice
d'anxiété préjudice d'anxiété a été
reconnu par la cour de cassation au
sujet des victimes de l'amiante
préjudice d'anxiété c'est extrêmement
simple
les victimes ont été exposés à l'amiante
elles ne sont pas malades elles n'ont
pas d'atteinte
en revanche elles ont des examens
récurrent à faire et elles vivent en
permanence avec cette angoisse de se
dire peut-être qu'un jour moi je vais
développer un mésothéliome et que je
vais partir en six mois
peut-être qu'un jour je vais avoir un
cancer broncho-pulmonaire voilà et et
vous connaissez bien le sujet de
l'amiante donc ici quand vous prenez la
définition de la joute donné par la cour
de cassation c'est pas quelque chose que
nous sortons notre chapeau c'est quelque
chose qui fait partie du droit positif
pour les victimes de l'amiante
nous sommes est
ac te ment dans la même situation c'est
à dire que les victimes qui ont pris ce
médicament même celles qui n'ont rien
d'un préjudice d'anxiété et il faudra
l'indemniser alors évidemment quand on
parle du préjudice n'a actionné
d'anxiété on commence et qui était
fortement parce que vous imaginez le
nombre de victimes
oui non mais oui
non mais tu t' d'avoir été pris d'avoir
pris ce médicament est de se dire est-ce
que je vais développer développer la
pathologie et de vivre avec ça c'est un
vrai problème mais ya pas qu elles les
victimes du death savez vous qu'une mère
aujourd'hui de famille kate dont la mère
a été exposée au dess peut se signaler à
la sécurité sociale quand elle quand
elle a une grossesse et elle est suivie
en tant que telle elle a un arrêt
maladie que vous avez voté qui est tout
à fait tout à fait mais est ce que moi
je les a pris et il ya peu ec ses
victimes du dsc mère de famille elles ne
sont pas suivies elles ne sont pas
remboursés à 100% pour leur suivi
parce qu'on suspecte des queues de la
dés l'apparition de cancer du sein chez
les femmes
mais quand elle veut si elles veulent se
faire dépister et bals seront remboursés
sur les bases du droit commun ne seront
pas prises en charge à 100%
c'est quand même extraordinaire c'est
quand extraordinaire eh bien ces
personnes elles ont aussi un préjudice
d'anxiété en se disant est ce que je
veux ou pas développer
vous voyez je veux dire si on change pas
radicalement avec sa sphère de l'amiante
le logiciel définitivement on va avoir
une judiciarisation qui va être
monstrueuse qui va être monstrueuse
voilà bien merci monsieur on va passer
donc maintenant aux questions alors
puisque jeu dépendra planteurs jeunes
tourner directement vers mes collègues
ici présents pour leur demander s'ils en
ont deux 2
s'exprimer et de poser des questions aux
intervenants
madame blandin hors de la fusion
d'autres agences l'afsset et la fsa pour
créer l'ansès la représentation
officielle des associations des usagers
qui existait à l'afsset a été
péniblement acquise mais acquise au sein
du conseil d'administration de l'ansès
quelle forme
la présence ou la parole sérieusement
écouter des associations de patients
pourraient prendre dans tout ce que vous
avez chacun évoqué des expertises d'usa
joue sous le nom d' expertise profanes
ou quelle forme ça pourrait prendre
oui madame la sénatrice par an je pense
que d'un dans cette affaire là il y a il
y à une véritable réflexion à mener qui
doit nous mener à la démocratie
sanitaire et à la reconnaissance des
associations d'usagers de la santé ou de
patients on a bien vu par les
différentes lois
d'abord les lois du droit de passer en
2002 puis 2004 que nous avions gagné une
place et que on voit bien on nous a mis
dans bon nombre de commissions un peu
partout et c'est pour faire bien plus
souvent observés de caution
ce que nous voulons nous c'est vrai
avant joué en rôle est effectivement
nous pensons que nous devons participer
d'abord à la gouvernance de ces agents
cela par les instances de gouvernance
revendiquer une place je conseille
d'être au conseil d'administration bien
entendu bien entendu et ensuite il est
bien évident que chacun d'entre nous a
une spécialité et de pathologies
et que c'est dans ce cadre-là de la
spécialité que nous devons être forts
auditionné soit participer à
l'élaboration que ce soit de
recommandations jeu soit 2,2 de
certificats watts
ensuite il est bien évident que derrière
cela il doit y avoir la reconnaissance
et des associations
certes aujourd'hui nous avons des
agréments nous avons la reconnaissance
d'utilité publique
il nous semble que nous devons là aussi
revoir et améliorer un petit peu cette
cette reconnaissance est que si vous
voulez que dans ce pays il y a une
véritable transparence une véritable
démocratie et que les patients puissent
participer cette expertise profane
puisse correspondre à un contrepoids des
expertises scientifiques
si vous voulez cela il va bien falloir
un moment donné que vous nous donner les
moyens de pouvoir fonctionne et surtout
pouvoir nous former formés et la
reconnaissance du bénévolat à la
reconnaissance de l'engagement bénévole
votre papa sépare pas par cela
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun financement
de la démocratie sanitaire si ce n'est
deux millions d'euros pour le collectif
interassociative et et 30000 euros pour
chacun rs ce qui est quand même tout à
fait dérisoire pour le nombre
d'associations et surtout pour la
nécessité de formations et de présence
juste un exemple un pompier bénévole
dans un village il est rénumérés au
moment de sa formation et augmente son
intervention je ne comprends pas
pourquoi un bénévole d'une association
aucune rénumération pour sa formation où
c'est très difficile et ne serez pas
énumérer s'il siège au conseil
d'administration d'une agence europe
de plus en plus de difficultés à trouver
des pompiers bénévoles
ouais je sais je sais c'est une non mais
où vous trouverez de moins en moins
aussi de patients bénévoles aussi et ce
sera véritablement que pour notre
démocratie si demain les associations
comme celles qui sont sur cette table ne
pouvait plus fonctionner ou ne serait là
que simplement pour une amicale
protection organisé le concours de
pétanque la vérité moi c'est pas du tout
notre mission c'est un autre volonté
d'engagement bénévole je le disais
récemment je trouve qu'aujourd'hui notre
engagement 10 s'est placée sous sur des
valeurs de solidarité d'entraidé de
partage à nous paraît aujourd'hui en
danger si véritablement il n'est pas mis
en place une règle c'est une démocratie
sa misère alors justement puisque vous
en êtes vous on va parler du financement
des associations
je pense qu'on ne peut pas éviter de
parler du financement par l'industrie
pharmaceutique de ces dites associations
vous ne l'avez pas parlé mais je vous en
parle je vous en parle c'est peut-être
un sujet secondaire mais qui à mes yeux
est quand même important par les temps
qui courent est et je me tourne vers
madame sophie le paquet lui demandait ce
qu'elle est subventionné par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
nous nous sommes subventionnés ni par
l'industrie pharmaceutique
ni par l'état votre réponse ne m'étonne
pas en ce qui concerne l'industrie
pharmaceutique parce que je vois mal
l'industrie pharmaceutique financer une
association qui a pour objectif
finalement de de critiquer les
médicaments c'est légèrement différent
c'est légèrement de légèrement différent
nous avons plus de 60% qui est de la
solidarité nationale qui est de dôme que
le budget de l'association qui sont
peut-être d'un complet ou en tout cas où
vous n'avez qu'à regarder sur le site
internet de là j'ai regardé toutes les
regarder sur site internet devrait dans
le budget de la chaise à hu est alors
non faut regarder sur le montois là le
nôtre est beaucoup plus précis que celui
de
santé j'ai constaté que vous vous êtes
bien si c'est vrai que vous receviez de
l'azuré pharmaceutique chaque année
enfin l'année dernière en tout cas 1 200
mille euros 200 milles 606 euros c c'est
un calculateur
nous recevons beaucoup plus que ça plus
à bon tout n'est pas dit que tout n'est
pas déclaré à l'autre sens et ayant
encore une ambiguïté très simplement
dans tous les laboratoires ne déclare
pas se leurrer ouvert ce qui ce qui ce
qui est du partenariat n'est pas
déclarée c'est que les dogues sont
déclarés à d'accord vous avez en plus le
partenariat n'est sûr bien sûr aller
mais allez sur notre site ou le moelleux
centaines d'euros et déclaré 4 millions
de budget pour l'association française
des diabétiques le siège national de 60%
c'est la générosité publique 25%
c'est l'industrie pharmaceutique et dans
les bonnes années l'état où l'on entre 5
et 10 pour ça nous surveillons très
attentivement à
ce financement là et pour vous dire
lequel ont surveillé le financement des
industries de l'industrie pharmaceutique
nous sommes que des partenariats jeu
nous montons nous mêmes des projets des
projets de prévention des projets
d'accompagnement des projets d'éducation
l'ensemble de la communauté des patients
diabétiques
c'est nous-mêmes qui réalise les projets
nous faisons appel d'offres et nous
demandons à ce qu'il y ait plusieurs
industriels qui viennent mettre de
l'argent pour la réalisation de ce
projet là ce sont des partenariats sont
des conventions signées tout à fait
public sur notre site
et auquel vous pouvez avoir accès tout à
fait et ça nous voulons être totalement
transparent
oui ou non mais la transparence ça
maintenant il ya peu je connais pas
quelqu'un qui s'oppose la transparence
amer et ça me pousse d'ailleurs -
problème c'est que finalement c'est pas
la transparence le vrai problème il ya
d'autres problèmes peut-être plus le
sénateur jeune homme est une question
très simple est ce que bon les
laboratoires sont pas des philanthropes
je pense que tout le monde est d'accord
ici alors pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
subventionnent par exemple votre
association et qui subventionne pas
celle de même le pallec parce qu'on
représente
parce qu'on représente 3 millions et
demi de passer 1 et que suivant les
chiffres l'om mais c'est vous le savez
très bien le diabète va se développer à
une vitesse vertigineuse
oui mais lorsque là il ya le source le
fait si nous subventionne c'est pour
quelles raisons
d'après vous je pense que parce qu'ils
ont compris notamment sur la pathologie
grave est que simplement le traitement
n'était pas la seule thérapie qu'il
fallait et qu'il fallait mettre en place
et qu' il y avait certainement aussi un
facteur d'accompagnement d'éducation et
et et de qualité de vie et que dans ce
cadre là je pense que l'industrie
pharmaceutique a parfaitement compris
qu'elle avait aussi un rôle d'éducation
et d'accompagnement mais c'est fait pour
ça que nous avons été extrêmement
vigilants sur la loi et sur l'arctique
la trentaine et articles de 61 2 3 sur
l'éducation et l'accompagnement ou à mon
sens vous ne l'avez pas été assez oui
mais je sais que les sénateurs et nous
mais nous verrons bien je pense que
l'industrie pharmaceutique ne peut pas
financer l'éducation thérapeutique
je suis d'accord avec un direct à fond -
directeur je suis tout à fait d'accord
j'ai partis associations comme la vôtre
c'est parce que ça il ya des retombées
forcément des retombées qui sont pas
nécessairement des retombées qui sont
utiles 1 à lyon à l'amélioration de la
qualité des soins qui sont destinés aux
diabétiques quelquefois ça peut arriver
mais ça n'est pas toujours le foot c'est
un jeu c'est qu'on aura mais non je veux
dire ce qui est entre le laboratoire et
les patients quel qu'il soit même
lorsqu'ils sont regroupés en association
qu'il y était médecin parce que les
médecins me semble-t-il sauce ait encore
des médecins qui n'est pas de liens
d'intérêts bien entendu avec l'industrie
vers la thématique a pas beaucoup me
direz vous mais y en a rien a et que ce
soit eux qui est la charge bien de
conduire cette éducation thérapeutique
parce que toute information qui émane
d'une entreprise quelle qu'elle soit ça
n'est pas une information
c'est de la publicité fait ça et oui
alors moi la proposition je vous fais si
par exemple et à s'engager à dire les
deux cent mille euros que vous verse aux
femmes un séjour est dit que c'était
plus un bon aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
est à peu près 800 millions si les
800000 euros
l'état s'engage à dire bah écoutez on
voulait on voulait à cordes et vous vous
acceptez de ne plus avoir de liens
financiers avec l'industrie
pharmaceutique
si vous dites oui y'a aucun souci
là-dessus mais justin voulait toujours
les avoir juste une précision
juste une précision l'information de
l'industrie pharmaceutique elle fait ce
qu'elle veut
ça c'est son problème sauf que
l'information faite par l'association
française des diabétiques est tout à
fait indépendante et c'est pas parce que
l'industrie pharmaceutique en finance le
son développement au sol sans
publication
quel est l'intérêt ou qu'elle les a mis
une virgule nous refusons effectivement
à ce que le contenu soit validée ou vu
par une souffrance
nous sommes totalement libre aux surnoms
nos publications et ça c'est très
mauvais ce la vie tous les médecins sont
libres si on ne lui voit pas influencer
par les visiteurs médicaux n'ont
certainement pas absolument certainement
penser que c'est ce qu'ils disent en
tout cas oui mais vous savez aux assises
du médicament je suis dans cette
commission là donc nous avons vu les
rythmes et danses et vous êtes plus fort
que les médecins vous n'êtes pas
influençable mais je pense qu'on est
elle fut en sable nous aussi bien
entendu là
porter il y a là un équilibre qui peut
se faire oui et justement j'ai pas vu
dans la liste de vos financeurs qui sont
vous avez raison de le dire très
nombreux j'ai pas vu le laboratoire
servier a bien j'ai l'habitude de dire
monsieur le sénateur il j'ai des
conflits d'intérêts avait tous les
industriels soient fin des séries vous
n'avez jamais eu non à oui c'est une
information qui est par les temps qui
courent qui n'est pas là complètement
bah oui très bien merci et je vais
passer d'abord la parole à monsieur
voleurs hennebert qui me l'a demandé
tout à l'heure je voudrais enfin moi sur
ce point mais j'avais une autre question
si du désastre le sur le financement
mais tu est évident que à partir du
moment vous demander aux industriels du
médicament dont le métier est de vendre
du médicament de faire de la prévention
ils vont contre leurs intérêts donc ça
paraît effectivement incompatibles c'est
une simple remarque mais elle ne peut
paraître bon sens
je voudrais revenir sur ce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure qui m'a paru fort
intéressant c'est le la réforme
systémique que sur la plupart des
banques j'ai entendu demande et réclamer
qui me paraît fort intéressante parce
que c'est vrai que s'en tenir uniquement
à la sphère du médiateur ce serait
réducteur et c'est bien d'ailleurs
l'objet de notre mission c'est d'élargir
le champ à une réflexion plus générale
sur la fonction du médicament et j'ai
trouvé deux des propositions fortes
intéressantes
je pense que nous pourrions
effectivement en faire une proposition
de la mission
simplement j'ai entendu sur le
représentants de l'afftac
j'ai félicité oui monsieur félicie
souhaité aller un peu plus loin et
demander aussi en faisant référence à
l'amiante une politique pénale de la
santé publique pour mc c'est qu'est ce
qu'on met dedans quoi politique pénale
de la santé publique de toute façon il
ya une politique pénale de santé
publique
la difficulté on l'a vu à propos de
l'amiante c'est c'est de remonter
jusqu'au coupable quand il ya un temps
de latence ou comme dans la sphère du
médiator on sait aussi que avant que la
sphère se déclenche il ya déjà eu des
victimes et que depuis est ce un
candidat et ça continuera donc la
difficulté mais ça me paraît quand même
un peu plus simple dans la sphère du
médiator parce qu'on connaît le
fabricant il n'en demeure pas moins que
la prescription est aussi à envisager
dans l' affaire pénale
et là vous aurez beaucoup de difficulté
à attendre les médecins qui ont prescrit
et dans quelles conditions
mais je pense que ce c'est bien de dire
qu'il faudrait une politique pénale de
santé publique
sauf que on voit pas bien comment on va
pouvoir la mettre en oeuvre avec tous
les égards que la justice doit avoir
vis-à-vis aussi bien des victimes que
des coupables alors et puis dernier
point j'ai jamais entendu parler alors
je sais pas peut-être marie christine
blandin a plus de mémoire que moi mais
dans la sphère de l'amiante qu'on a bien
suivi le préjudice d'anxiété
oui certes mais j'ai jamais entendu
parler qu'on puisse indemniser qu'on
puisse prendre en compte le préjudice
d'anxiété comment voulez vous mesurer
cela l' angoisse de l'amour leur devoir
ciliopée pas la cause de la mort n'a
donc jamais entendu parler de ça mais ce
soir si on lis et même si on le sait
beaucoup de victimes de l'amiante
redoutent d'aller passer les examens
complémentaires pour vérifier
annuellement je crois que c'est à peu
près le temps qui est le timing qui est
prévu redoute d'aller faire cet examen
mais ça c'est une angoisse quand même
qui est un petit peu différente que
louer de l'angoissé existentielle
c'est une angoisse qui est quand même
qu'ils résultent mesure à mesure à plein
temps avec l'angoissé existentielle son
préjudice et techno on appris de la
justice on a pris en compte le préjudice
dans ses affaires par est juste légitime
au niveau de la retraite mais il est
difficile de le prendre au delà bien
vous madame blandin juste une réponse
le préjudice d'anxiété n'a pas été
individualisées dans aucune démarche
simplement il a été plaidée par les
avocats pendant les démarches normal de
revendications des victimes
en même temps d'ailleurs que le
préjudice de excusez moi le terme de
décote sur le marché du travail
pour avoir travaillé dans un lieux
contaminés et quand vous parlez d'une
politique pénale spécifique sanitaires
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
les procès échoue pas seulement parce
qu'à pas de politiques spécifiques mais
parce qu'à un arsenal périphériques qui
permet dé de botter en touche on à la
faute non intentionnelle qui est
utilisée systématiquement est une des
seules condamnation de l'employeur avec
des indemnités très lourdes pour les
victimes réelles et les victimes
potentielles a eu lieu au tribunal de
lille
uniquement parce que les avocats ont pu
mettre sur la table la politique
régionale qu'on avait mené de
désamiantage des lycées de pi 93 en
inondant les mairies la presse etc
sur l'épreuve du danger de l'amiante et
ça a servi aux avocats dont et quand
vous évoquez le pôle santé de paris
je rappelle que son manque d'eau pj et
son manque de juges de greffiers et
cetera pèse pratiquement aussi lourd
qu'une absence de politique sanitaire
pénale spécifique quoi y'a aussi tout ça
à toiletter quoi sans refuser votre
proposition
non on en voit mal les contours voilà
alors je fais ici veut peut-être je vais
essayer de faire vite et parce que je
vais pas emboliser le sujet qu'en ce qui
concerne préjudice d'anxiété
c'est bien la preuve et et vous
m'envoyez réjouit qui qu'on est encore
sous l'égide de montesquieu que le
pouvoir législatif est indépendant du
pouvoir judiciaire parce que
manifestement le pouvoir législatif ici
présents ignore que la cour de cassation
à pouvoir y a pas de pouvoir judiciaire
oui malheureusement jane rhodes vous
avez raison c'est une autorité mais je
le regrette mais la cour de cassation
par un arrêt du 10 mai 2010 pour les
victimes de l'amiante a reconnu un
préjudice d'anxiété
en dix ans les chaussures on vous fera
passer cet art est bien évidemment et
tous les commentaires de doctrine qui on
était
rendu à ce sujet parce que c'est quand
même une évolution majeure du droit
prétend rien certes par pas législatif
mais pourquoi pas que le législateur ne
se saisissent de cette évolution
la cour de cassation il y en a qu'une
seule
oui oui oui non ces lacs où c'est le
plus haut degré de juridiction en france
celui qui dit le droit
je suppute quelques cours d'appel
madame blandin je ne sais plus de quel
cour d'appel en tout cas le droit a dit
la cour de cassation juridiction qui dit
le droit a dit en parlant des victimes
qu'elle se trouvait dans une situation
d'inquiétude permanente face au risque
de déclaration à tout moment d'une
maladie liée à l'amiante et été amenés à
subir des contrôles et examens réguliers
propres à réactiver cette angoisse
voilà la définition de préjudice
d'anxiété en droit français aujourd'hui
bon ça mais je veux dire c'est pas
quelque chose qui n'existe pas
j'entendais tout à l'heure qu'on me dit
comme disait ça n'existe pas qu'est ce
que c'est que ce machin n'en avait pas
entendu parler dans la sphère de
l'amiante mais vous signaler que ça a
été pris en compte par la cour de
cassation
je voudrais y voir les conséquences mais
je vais on va vous envoyer l'art et les
doctrines nous ça fait 15 ans complètent
ce préjudice d'anxiété on à en faire
arriver à le faire à le faire admettre
en droit français
ensuite en ce qui concerne vous faisiez
tout à l'heure allusion à la loi fauchon
à la à l'arsenal vous faisiez allusion
au manque de moyens du pôle de santé
publique dans la sénatrice je ne peux
que vous serrez la main parce que ce
n'est pas moi qui rédige les lois ce
n'est pas moi et c'est pas une attaque
c'est pas un truc non mais c'est un
constat je veux dire c'est pas moi qui
écrit lol moi je n'écris pas la loi
ce n'est pas moi qui a rédigé la loi
fauchon sur le sur effectivement ce que
vous ce que vous mentionnez ce n'est pas
moi qui vote le budget de la justice
tous les ans et si c'était la fnath
on aurait sans doute un déficit encore
plus important ce qui je vous le concède
mais je pense que j'aurais tripler le
nombre de greffiers au pôle de santé
publique de paris est géré quadrupler le
nombre d'objets et doubler le nombre de
magistrats
ça c'est clair et on aurait peut-être
c'est parce que la politique pénale
c'est pas de dire est loin de là loin de
là pour moi c'est pas moi qui vais vous
faire 7 7
cette diatribe la politique pénale c'est
pas de dire on va on va faire du
répressif ont dit on va dire que lui va
faire tant d'années de prison un rat
tant d'années n'a maintenant la
politique pénale c'est la découverte
d'une criminalité particulière et une
politique spécifique pour avec des
moyens spécifiques autant dans la
prévention que dans la répression avec
des incrimination spécifique parce que
aujourd'hui je suis navrée mais sur la
responsabilité des personnes morales on
est encore au stade préhistorique
on a des petites amendes est là qui
traîne par rapport à ddd chiffre
d'affaires 2 milliard et 2 milliards
mais est ce qu'on a dans ce pays sans
doute oui vous faisiez tout à l'heure
allusion à votre rapport resté dans un
tiroir depuis 54 apport remarquable non
mais je suis pas bien sûr
non mais c'est vrai la chose est vraie
on sera très peu dire depuis mai on a
réfléchi à ce qui était rapporté pense
que dans ce pays on a réfléchi sur la
responsabilité des grands groupes en
termes de responsabilité pénale
et là j'en viens à un propos que je te
jeu qui nous est que je trouve très
important parce que ce qui ce qui a été
dit tout à l'heure me gêne moi enfin la
fnath
on n'a jamais pensé qu'on ne pouvait pas
alors en ce qui concerne le financement
nous ne nous sommes pauvres 1 personne
nous financent donc est ce qu'on n'est
pas de financement de l'industrie verte
vous voyez nous sommes trop maigre pour
être malhonnête nous avons que la peau
sur les zones non non on a des
subventions qu'on demande à l'état
voilà mes mais bref c'est pas le sujet
je dire nous nous sommes à la cnam et on
vous citiez tout à l'heure son nom et on
doit rendre à césar ce qui appartient à
césar
l'intelligence de xavier bertrand sur
les entretiens du médicament sa grande
intelligence
c'est d'avoir mis en face tout le monde
et il a et nous nous avons toute
confiance en ce ministre parce que je
pense que même si c'est difficile il
aura là je devrais pas utiliser ce mot
là parce que c'est un ministre de notre
public mais il à la poigne pour imposer
un changement et il a mis il a eu
l'intelligence et la lente et je sais
pas ce qui sortira des entretiens du
médicament ça c'est un autre sujet mais
il a eu l'intelligence de mettre face à
face des gens qui ne se parlent pas
d'accord ou qui refusent de se parler ou
qui ne se parlent que devant les
tribunaux
nous on n'a pas cette culture là à la
fnath où nous on est disposé à parler
avec les entreprises du médicament
demain on est disposé à organiser une
convention et a parlé avec les
entreprises du médicament sur cette
problématique du risque dans sa
globalité
parce que nous nous pensons et c'est la
fnath qui vous le dit que le business
c'est pas honteux de gagner de l'argent
y compris avec le médicament ya rien
dans thalassa et contraire ça crée des
emplois
c'est un progrès moi je vous comme moi
moi je n'aimerais pas du tout que un de
mes enfants ou un de mes proches 17
d'une pneumonie parce qu'il n'ya pas
l'anti bid le bon antibiotiques c'est
n'importe quoi d'avoir cette position ce
qu'on dit simplement c'est que nous on
n'a pas cette culture on a la culture de
la caisse nationale d'assurance maladie
nous sommes fnath association de
victimes du travail on a en face de nous
les employeurs ce qui crée le risque est
qu'ils produisent des sinistres on sait
jamais sharp et on travaille ensemble on
monte sur des actions de prévention
ensemble je veux dire tout ça se fait
naturellement on a la culture du fiva
dieu sait que le fiva on a la culture du
chiva moi j'ai de très bonnes relations
avec les représentants des employeurs
j'aimerais j'arrête je termine sur ça je
dis que moi je dis que si on est dans
une politique du risque
socialiser avec un avec une solvabilité
à sion par l'assurance quelle qu'elle
soit on arrivera parler avec les
entreprises du médicament dans un autre
registre que celui des tribunaux que
celui des de l'infréquentable les
entreprises du médicament ne sont pas
infréquentable
il faut simplement imposer une notion de
risque accepté et socialiser avec l
mutualisé par elle et on pourra discuter
de prévention non parce qu'il ya une
dernière question que je voudrais vous
poser
socke si mes collègues en ont encore
d'autres mais personne n'a parlé des des
actions de groupe
c'est dans parmi eux alors je voulais
savoir si c'était volontaire si c'est
parce que c'est parce que je constate eu
et on parlait tout à l'heure de
l'isoméride là je m'suis d'être courtois
l'isoméride aux états unis ça représente
pour le laboratoire qu'il a
commercialisé une une dépense qui est
estimé à 15 milliards d'euros
je dis bien milliards d'euros en france
où je l'avais indiqué si on cumule les
deux affaires à ça fait six cent mille
sept cent mille euros
les quatre affaires je crois que c'est à
ce prix là voilà alors oui là et
effectivement je dis pas que ce sont les
actions de groupes qui vont faire la
différence mais c'est quand un système
qui aux états unis a l'air de marcher
très bien parce que contrairement à ce
qu'on croit souvent les tribunaux n'ont
même pas besoin d'intervenir ce sont
souvent des transactions wignehies ont
lieu en amont parce que le tribunal est
dissuasif 1 et oui mais les transactions
sont quand même très dur alors je
voulais savoir ce que vous en pensiez
difficilement transposable en france
avait fait deux avocats américains qui
sont venus voir la semaine dernière qui
est keith urban qui est de new york et
puis un autre qui est de santa clara en
californie
il voulait voir si effectivement il
pouvait apporter afin j'ai bien compris
ce qui venait voir uv jetons mais si
vous voulez ce qu'il voulait c'est
qu'est des dizaines de milliers
victimes regroupées que toutes les
associations se regroupent
parce qu'ils nous ont expliqué si vous
les clés aux états unis les laboratoires
avaient des avocats qu'ils paient très
cher et qu'en contrepartie il était
normal que les avocats américains qui
prennent les victimes soient aussi payer
très cher donc ça mais j'avais mille 500
et 1500 victimes en plus de celles qui
ont déposé plainte donc ça l'intéressé
pinte
mais il a expliqué par exemple aux états
unis là la condamnation du laboratoire
sur le plan pénal si vous voulez pour
l'isoméride c'était 4,3 milliards de
dollars
donc c'est dissuasif c'est à dire en
plus de ce qu'ils doivent indemniser le
laboratoire savait qu'il allait être
condamné à caviar donc qu'il a préféré
si vous voulez faire effectivement fait
y avait une action de groupe il a
préféré payer mais par exemple aux
etats-unis une victimes de l'isoméride a
touché 4 135 millions de dollars dont on
n'est pas du tout si vous voulez dans
les mêmes rapports par rapport à la
france et puis si on dit 435 millions de
dollars c'est quand même super yeux
rivés fabricants de housses il n'est pas
décédé donc c'est vrai on est dans des
barèmes qui sont totalement différents
c'est pas la même culture et en plus
mais c'est pas méchant ce que je dis si
vous voulez je vois pas en france les
avocats et on l'a bien vu dans la sphère
du médiateur ou ça part dans tous les
sens on voit pas les avocats se
regrouper si vous voulez et avoir une
action commune avoir des avocats
spécialisés qui seraient regroupés et
qui aiderait les les victimes
et c'est vrai ce que disait d'ailleurs
monsieur sa route l'autre jour autant
dans le ski et le sida on avait un petit
peu une conscience dans sa fin on avait
en là pour le médiator ça part dans tous
les sens mais par contre on pourrait
faire pas forcément une class action à
l'américaine mais on pourrait quand même
mettre les bases d'une action à la
française ça je pense que c'est possible
peut-être pas avec les mêmes critères
mais c'est possible et pourquoi pas en
choisir l'occasion du médiator pour
essayer d'en rediscuter d'accord bien
donc plus personne
ne voulant intervenir là on a une une
ponctualité extra bien voulu intervenir
monsieur donc oui je veux dire pour les
syndromes de laguiole ça n'a pas lieu
d'être puisque on n'a pas suffisamment
de victimes
oui par molécule pour se retourner
contre un laboratoire précis sachant
qu'avec les les génériques
ça réduit encore cette possibilité donc
le seul contre qui on pourrait se
retourner c'est dans une action de
groupe c'est l'état en fait d'accord
très bien bon plus personne ne voulant
intervenir deux allons lever la séance
et je vous remercie
c'est la fin de cette table ronde
consacrée au scandale du médiator je
vous rappelle que toutes les auditions
de la mission d'information du sénat sur
le médiator sont disponibles en vod sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr je
vous donne rendez vous cet après midi à
partir de 17h pour suivre en direct sur
notre antenne
les questions cribles thématiques elles
sont consacrés aujourd'hui aux problèmes
énergétiques très bonne journée à tous
sur public sénat